hydras have fascinated biologists for  centuries thanks to their spectacular  regeneration abilities they can  withstand all manner of violence  scientists have even Blended hydras down  to their cellular components spun them  in a centrifuge so they pack together  and watched as the cells sort themselves  back into Hydra which is why Hydra are  sometimes called the Eternal embryo this  is not to say they cannot die if food  runs low or water quality becomes poor  or something eats them then yes the  Hydra too will succumb but scientists  studying Hydra over several years have  found no sign of Aging in the organisms  which means that barring all of those  challenges we mentioned earlier hydras  may be immortal